it is so messed up to think that your
life only matters to you you can't save
me I'm so excited for season 2 this show
has really taken off and just resonated
with so many people why do you think
that is I think we're telling stories
about real people and that's something
that's hard to come across on television
these days and we look like America and
and our relationships with each other
are real and the people want to see that
they want to see themselves represented
season 2 where do you guys pick up funny
it's gonna be you know the Ematic with
some of this season a lot of faces new
faces anything that surprised you guys
reading those scripts procedures we just
filmed yesterday I said I'm mad what I
showed is that we do a lot of gasping
when we read we do Wow so that when the
scripts come to our emails we're like
binging like and texting each other like
oh my god this just how am i we're
reading it together as we tag they're
talking how do you think fans are gonna
feel about season 2 mm I think you're
giving them they will definitely be
happy yeah we're stepping at the drama
we're stepping it up a notch for sure
they're gonna love it this guy's quiet
over here all the mics all the way over
there but yeah I think the audience is
gonna love it it's gonna have a lot of
mixed feelings of course like say like
with Jamie and gaël it's gonna be a lot
of little twists and turns that causes
some people to comment team Kyle or team
Jamie on all the use of Grandpa is there
one scene in particular that you cannot
wait for fans to see yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yes we can involves the pool who in the
pool hard because your show is there's
like mysteries to it right and there's
like cliffhangers and there's things
that we want answers to do your family
members come and bug you for answers and
you keep your mouth shut
mind oh yeah we also bug the writers we
don't know anything like what happened
Zak yeah I'm always like stumbling into
the writers only looking at the board
like what they're writing my dad's on
coworkers come to me for you know wisdom
they want to hear they want to know
everything and they're in there like
superfans too easy to binge and also to
get addicted to and I think that's what
people love about it so much is like
juicy right yeah a little bit for
everyone you know I feel like someone
can see themselves in at least one
character you know so that's exciting
yeah what's the number one question from
season one that you guys are excited to
answer in season two you have an answer
so I don't know if I want to give that
away the answer is yes little tease
maybe describe it in three like the
first episode back in season two how
would you describe it in three words
oh the first episode nerve-wracking
intense I that's all I can say five
words we're gonna have everyone give a
word five words will they won't they
oh hi everybody I said well they won't
that surprising yeah no I'm just this is
this really big fight overly intense its
intense there's a lot it's a lot of
information coming at you and it's a lot
of questions answered
and a lot of more questions you're gonna
have